the movie opens up in a dimly lit
skating rink where the main character
Sebastian and his young daughter Anna
are happily skating together however
their Pleasant time is short-lived as
they're forced to leave when loud noises
startle them as they cautiously make
their way out they are ambushed by
desperate blind Bandits who steal all of
their canned food Sebastian considers
fighting back I mean they're blind after
all but Anna tells him not to outside we
see that the city of Barcelona has
fallen victim to an apocalyptic
catastrophe leaving only a few survivors
a mysterious Supernatural entity seems
to have taken control over the entire
continent and anyone who looks at it
will be manipulated to commit the
unthinkable while the entity cannot
physically harm people it can instead
manipulate individuals through their
emotions and drive them to take their
own lives Sebastian and Anna venture out
into the streets wearing specially
designed eye goggles covered in black
paint ensuring they do not even
accidentally catch a glimpse of the
terrifying monsters shortly after they
come across another group of survivors
and Sebastian pleads to join them in
order to gain their trust he claims that
he is a former construction engineer who
can help them set up a generator for
light and indoor heating convinced by
his offer the group allows him to join
them and he asks Anna to wait for him
until he ensures that the group is safe
following this the group takes Sebastian
to their Camp which is an abandoned bus
station there he meets a doctor who
tends to his wounds he also meets with
another fellow Survivor who has stitched
his eyes in order to save himself from
the entity The Man reveals that while
many people feared the mysterious entity
some possessed the ability to roam
around the city without the need for
blindfolds who are regarded as the seers
however these Sears now serve as
Messengers for the entity unbeknownst to
the group Sebastian is one of these
seers having seen the monster himself in
the early hours of the morning while the
rest of the group is sleeping inside a
boss Sebastian quietly enters the
driver's compartment locks the door from
inside and starts the engine the group
members quickly wake up and try to stop
him but Sebastian refuses he drives the
bus out from their Hideout and into the
outside world where the group faces
immediate attacks from the mysterious
entity that manipulates each of them to
kill themselves one after another one of
them commits The Unthinkable by lighting
himself on fire while another uses A
Shard of glass and a third binge watches
James Corden until his head explodes
here it is revealed that Sebastian is a
Seer who lost his daughter to the
Insidious creature and the figure he
sees is actually her spectral form he
has now taken on the responsibility of
seeking out other survivors in the city
and forcing them to look at the entity
leading them to end their lives in his
perspective this act is a way of
liberating their souls so that they can
be reunited in the afterlife with their
loved ones the scene then cuts to a
flashback nine months prior Where it All
Began on that fateful day Sebastian was
at his work place and saw the news of
the Apocalypse spreading across various
regions in Europe worried about his
family he rushed to his daughter's
school outside he witnessed the
horrifying effects of people succumbing
to The Entity regardless he somehow
managed to collect Anna and on their way
home they came across a local Church's
priest named father Esteban unlike
others the priest had a different
perspective viewing the entity as a holy
spirit in the apocalypse as a Divine
Miracle however Sebastian avoided him
and returned home to his wife who is
waiting for them they were about to
drive away but suddenly a car came out
of nowhere and hit his wife leading to
her death after this incident Sebastian
was left alone to take care of his young
daughter and he really struggled to
survive in the post-apocalyptic World
Sebastian and Anna then sought Solas in
a secluded area attempting to find some
happiness in their harsh reality however
their peace was abruptly disrupted when
a group of seers led by father Esteban
discovered their hiding spot and
captured both father and daughter the
priest appoint Sebastian to become a
Seer like them while he cruelly forced
Anna to open her eyes manipulating her
to commit the unthinkable after this
tragic incident Sebastian often has
visions of Anna beside him but
unbeknownst to him she is just another
form of the entity sometimes the entity
presents itself to me as a McChicken
into poutine and then I eat them in the
present Sebastian finds a new group of
people to take him in using his
generator trick once again this new
group includes an English woman named
Claire a young German girl named Sophia
who is around the same age as Anna an
elderly couple named Roberto and
Isabelle and two other men named Rafa
and Octavio along with their dogs
fortunately this time not a machine gun
Kelly inside already died the group
leads Sebastian to their underground
hideout and then inquires about the
whereabouts of the generator to their
dismay Sebastian admits that he just
made it up which infuriates the group
and orders him to leave however the
group changes their decision when he
showcases his multilingual skills
enabling him to come communicate with
Sophia Sebastian then translates
Sophia's story revealing that she got
separated from her mother during their
trip to Barcelona she also mentions a
mountain castle which is believed to be
a safe haven and where her mother is
currently staying in addition she
explains it to them by drawing a picture
of the castle and a cable car that leads
to it in the next scene the cunning
Sebastian persuades the group to head to
the mountain castle he also tampers with
the dog leashes so that they easily
break upon slight impact the next day
the group Ventures out on their Journey
but on the way they are confronted by
The Entity who takes on the form of
their lost loved ones the apparitions
create chaos and distraction and the
dogs break free from their leashes and
run away when Rafa removes his blindfold
to catch them he sees the entity and is
forced to commit the unthinkable amidst
the turmoil Roberto is also bitten by
one of the dogs in a state of panic the
rest of the group members hide in an
apartment and shut all the doors and
windows before opening their blindfolds
after this Octavio Sophia Claire and
Sebastian climb upstairs in search of
some medical supplies for Roberto during
this Anna's manipulative influence over
Sebastian leads him to open a window
resulting in Octavio's demise Anna
further urges her father to remove the
blindfolds of Claire and Sophia but for
the first time he hesitates and begins
to question the morality of his actions
and his beliefs after a while the
shell-shocked group continues their
Journey towards the mountain castle
along the way they find themselves
pursued by a group of seers forcing
themselves to run for their lives sadly
Roberto and Isabel are left behind
during the chase Claire implore
Sebastian to go back and save them but
he insists on leading the group to a
nearby house as a result the Elder
couple looks at each other and kisses
for one last time before being killed
inside the house Claire vents her anger
towards Sebastian calling him selfish
for abandoning the Elder couple soon
after she learns that Sebastian is also
a Seer and therefore decides to distance
herself from him Sebastian tries to
explain blame that he means no harm and
genuinely wants to help them but his
attempts fall on deaf ears in the midst
of this discussion Anna's persistent
influence continues urging him to free
their soul as he has been doing before
but once again Sebastian resists in his
influence saying that she is only a mere
hallucination in the next scene Claire
and Sophia put on their blindfolds and
run away from the house however
Sebastian follows them to the rooftop
trying once more to persuade them
somehow he manages to bring them back
inside and reveals about his daughter
along with the influence she had over
him he then genuinely expresses his
desire to help them just then their
conversation is interrupted when they
spot father Esteban and his followers
approaching being a Seer Sebastian
guides Claire and Sophia out of the
building during their escape their way
is blocked by one of the priest's
followers who see Sebastian as a traitor
and attacks him she attempts to gouge
out his eyes claiming he does not
deserve to see a fierce brawl that
ensues between the two of them but
Sebastian somehow manages to throw her
off the building see you later following
the intense Chase Sebastian brings
Claire and Sophia to a car and drives
towards a tall tower equipped with cable
cars that lead to the mountain castle
imagine this the Relentless Pursuit by
the priest and his henchmen continues
upon arriving at the tower Sebastian
instructs Claire to take Sophia and
proceed while he decides to stay back
and stop father Esteban following his
orders Claire and Sophia start climbing
the stairs to the top of the tower but
at one point a weak step breaks nearly
causing Sophia to fall fortunately
Claire manages to hold her tight and
pull her up before resuming their climb
concern for their safety in their
further way Claire decides to remove her
blindfold momentarily eventually the two
manage to get inside the control room on
the top only to discover that the cable
cars are currently inoperable Claire
spots a large Bell and Rings it
successfully activating the cable cars
however the vibration from the Bell also
attracts the attention of the entity as
it approaches them slowly the
surroundings begin to tremble including
the cable cars it desperately attempts
to lure Clarence Sophia by imitating the
voices of their loved ones it's me girls
Timothy chalamet but the determined Duo
resists the Temptation and safely boards
one of the cable cars making their way
to the mountain castle unharmed on the
other hand Sebastian manages to stab the
priest with an iron Rod body also
sustains a critical injury in the
process both men succumb to their wounds
but Sebastian in his final moments is
relieved to see Claire and Sophia's safe
departure to the mountain castle upon
reaching the castle the two notice that
the entire place has been transformed
into a community of its own with
military personnel maintaining security
it appears that the castle has become a
self-sufficient Sanctuary for a majority
of the survivors in Barcelona shortly
after their arrival we also see an
emotional reunion between Sophia and her
mother afterwards Claire is taken to a
laboratory where some research teachers
conduct blood tests on her curious about
the purpose of these tests she inquires
and one of the researchers explains that
they are conducting these tests to find
a chemical indicator an epigenetic
alteration which could help them
identify signs of extreme stress and
specific emotions targeted by the entity
in other words we're just adding in a
bunch of jargon so we can make
a third movie The researcher also
reveals that in some rare cases
individuals who have experienced extreme
stress and Trauma undergo an alteration
in their DNA rendering them immune to
the effects of the entity this explains
how Sebastian after the devastating loss
of his daughter became a Seer instead of
being manipulated additionally the
researcher discloses their efforts to
develop a vaccine against the monsters
using blood from a captured seer in the
final scene the researchers are seen
carrying out their experiment by
injecting an epigenetic antibody into
rats and placing their cages inside a
sealed chamber unfortunately the outcome
is far from promising as menacing
growling sound emerges from the chamber
and the Rats perish indicating that the
vaccine compound has not yet proven
effective it's going to take at least
three more movies and a mini series two
probably subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching